[Music]
so
brad pitts in the news these days
he's back he has a girlfriend
i thought he was with the angelina jolie
what what
dude they divorced they divorced four
years ago
oh well i haven't been a part of society
for the last seven years so
true is he back with jennifer aniston no
oh so he's dating this 27 year old
she's freaking hot does that make him a
molester
uh probably not because probably not 27.
no but then like he's like 60 though oh
he's 56
not 60 dude not even close okay
i'm just saying all i'm saying is okay
i think that people don't think it's
gross when you look good
it's it's it's it's looks shaming if he
was
27 is if he was a 57 year old
ugly nasty dude that
you know that's nasty and then it was a
27 year old like
model they'll be like oh look at him
he's so disgusting
but it is brad pitt so it's like oh he's
so handsome well because you know he
takes care of himself and like
is talented and but you painted this you
painted this guy to be disgusting even
without the girl
yeah it was just that disgusting too
what if like yeah disgusting by himself
but like no it's like how dare he he's
molesting you sound like a hater
you're like how dare he get it what if
you would no i wouldn't no for me i'm
just like i'm
i'm down now for what for anybody
[ __ ]
everybody well except for like if it's
illegal oh right right but i'm just
saying like
i'm just saying like gotta cover your
faces yeah these days especially
but i'm saying like i think that there
is
a double standard if you look good or if
you don't look good
for old dudes yeah because if you if you
look good as an old dude
i don't know i would still be like
i think it's just a standard i mean you
have the standard for both yeah i think
it's standard even if it's the same age
if one guy is a hot mess you're just
like
why is this happening probably but there
is like the age thing about it too like
if it's a
40-year gap i do personally go like
why not me but then you're if oh you
know what you're right
okay let's say it was a 57 year old
disgusting man
with a 27 year old disgusting woman then
no one questions it they can yeah
they're meant for that no
i would still be like interesting tell
me more
just the age gap that makes it weird so
what about 40
and 80. that's weird
for me 80s a little still growth yeah
but even though for me
too old nasty if it's more than like
10 years for me personally it's like
10 years that's not that's not that bad
what are you talking about no that's why
if it's like 11 or 12 years then it's
like
no but 10.
but if it's 11 10 okay yes that's where
i draw the line a hard line
so 48 somewhere 40 and 50 is okay 39 and
50.
nope it can't happen you can't nope not
for my standards
that's interesting okay so
the story here this model guess what
she's married wait so he's
like what a homewrecker he is he's
wrecking her home
so she is married why is her face so
angled
they can't even see her because she's
modeling oh
she's saying i'm married i got a
boyfriend she's
married and she has a boyfriend and it's
brad pitt okay so her husband
she has been married for the last eight
years
she's a fat 80 year old she has a
seven-year-old with this
husband of hers and he
he is this owner uh of this really
famous restaurant in germany and so
that's wienerschnitzel
so the owner of this restaurant his name
is roland mary
and he's 68 years old god dang this girl
look
that's nice she loves she's a grandpa
chaser
yeah and then there's gives me hope
they're saying that they actually
so she met brad pitt at this restaurant
because
back in 2009 when he was filming in
glorious bastards on location
i love that movie in germany he went to
this restaurant
and that's where they met and then
shortly after that the model
nicole she flew over to or like she gave
brad pitt her
number it's brad pitt flew to l.a for a
medallion
modeling job she flew to la for modeling
job and then hit him up and then they
they started seeing each other this and
then they were seen
at the hollywood bowl here in l.a back
in november of 2019
and they were pictured together in the
vip area at kanye west's
concert yay they're saying that like
since then they've
so they're putting the pieces together
and stuff but is she still married
she is still currently married is it an
open man
it is why does he look like future brad
pitt
well actually he looks like george
clooney but older so this is roland mary
right that guy is disgusting he is not
my type that guy's disgusting
and then that guy makes brad pitt look
like he's 17.
i told you guys see there's a uh there's
a
there's a there's a there's a stigma of
ugly if you see a hot person without go
for
brad pitt though and i think he's
handsome but i wouldn't he's too old
yeah but then like
but when you see this you don't go you
go
damn she got brad pitt like goop or her
yeah you don't go you don't go all brad
man you got this hot ass young that's
what i think
i don't think so seriously because she
upgrades her life like [ __ ] crazy
with him get anybody
yep that's right she could get anyone
looking no but
he could get he could get 20 of hers
she's a dime a dozen a bunch of models
that's um doesn't she here's only one
brand she is her own person bart
there's only one of her a dime for a
half dozen
he's proven to the world but that's
[ __ ] brad pitt i know
if it was okay like if it was like
jennifer aniston or like someone like
with an that's really top-notch right
she's just pretty
yeah which is not a skill it's like well
you're a model
yeah great you know it's nice but you're
not well you know what's crazy
so she's she has a beauty and brains
because she is a doctor
a doctor no i'm just kidding no she's
not no uh yeah but she's not naomi
campbell is what i'm saying she's not
like top tier
brad pitt is a top-tier [ __ ]
right yeah so it's like
yeah he got someone young and hot but he
can always get that i got you
yeah yeah yeah that's that's what he's
royalty yeah he didn't get oprah
if he got with oprah that's a power
couple yeah oh
he went with the top notch like jay-z
and beyonce yes
then next to oprah he's a diamond dozen
that's true how many [ __ ] actors are
there a billion of them how many operas
i got you there is only one oprah yeah
yeah
dr phil though the time she made doc
i mean she made dr phil that's true
that's true
that guy took all the saliva out of my
mouth
that guy's so dry-looking yeah i don't
really feel bad for life he goes like
this and himalayan sea salt just comes
out
well this guy look at something
i could picture his dry crack oh that
guy's so nasty
that's so mean why did you put that in
my brain it's money though forgot bonita
[ __ ]
fish flakes this dude has been married
about four
i think maybe five times i forgot the
exact number but he's been married
multiple times
the to all hot models i i don't know
but um they are mentioning that because
he's been in
you know so many relationships in the
past he has five kids including the one
that he has with
damn he is not about negativity or
jealousy so that's why he's
cool with him like his wife dating brad
pitt he's like i have
so much [ __ ] uh that's fine cher
27 so he's like i'm not gonna try to
contain her or anything like
she can live her life i'm sure he has so
many girlfriends himself yeah that's
true
who knows that kind of sounds fun this
is just a different world yeah
it's a different world of dating it's
like royalty dating
people yeah it's like everyone is what
the rules are that they operate
and then you know it's funny because um
okay so
you think like celebrities like you
they'll have their [ __ ] together they
won't be as petty right as
normal people but no brad pitt recently
he went
he took nicole to france the south of
france
and took her to his chateau which he
bought with angelina which they are
like they're still having a custody
battle after they're
like they're they're technically
divorced but they're still going to
court
and also the chateau has been like a
thing that they have been fighting over
and so
brad pitt took nicole over there when it
was supposed to be their wedding
anniversary with brad and angelina the
same time
he's still mad it was their wedding and
they got married at oh that's why
they got they got married at the chateau
oh that's why it was like even more
petty
it's like mr mrs smith part
why because they're still fighting oh mr
mrs schnitzel
schnitzel this is schnitzer
yeah and then they were saying like each
other's like like celebrity gossip [ __ ]
they're like
oh yeah brad knows that angelina's
probably gonna get very upset
that but he doesn't care i mean honestly
the fact that this [ __ ]
is even news is crazy to me i just feel
like
there's so many different things and
like in the world
obviously right now we care about i care
about i
care about celebrities [ __ ] right now
because there's too much [ __ ] going on
well i'm like i need a little break yes
let me just talk some [ __ ] about
something
and i'll get back to the real [ __ ] it's
it is still though i feel like gossip
about like cheating or whatever people
might think
is not in the norm so i i understand it
and a part of me also enjoys reading
this
i feel like people listen to this and go
thank god
these people are doing it too true maybe
it makes some people
not feel alone yeah which is cool but it
just doesn't relate to me
yeah but a little bit you said but
little part of me is like guilty
pleasure i'm like whoa okay
i do i feel you about the jennifer
aniston thing though but do you
i feel like they should be together in
my mind do you feel like
no it's ross and rachel bro
forever do you ever feel like when you
see this
stereotype right like oh dude with model
oh rich dude model right you go
like man i wonder
if he can still [ __ ] i think about that
right i thought about that with like
hugh hefner yeah in those days i i was
thinking if he was like
having sex with his plenty of
girlfriends they said
like one of the playboy bunnies you know
how they all talked
like publicly or no even when he was
like there's like a couple of them
like three of them i lived with them
right yeah yeah so
one of them said that the way that they
would have sex with him is like they
would just lay down
he'd come up to them like he'd be
jerking off first and then
going up to him like sticking a little
bit and then he always
finished by himself what do you mean
like he would just come on himself
would would come yeah on come on his own
so he'll be like
don't touch me
i'll do it myself that's how he stayed
alive for so long it was the protein and
the semen that he was drinking there we
go
that's so funny i like how he caught it
oh he was busting it himself you know
[Music]
do